bonjour bienvenue lors d'un glissement
pour une chambre
je préfère vous prévenir l'hôtel est un
petit peu hanté vous avaient péri en
krav un des petits bruits à droite à
gauche a mené peur de rien ça fait
longtemps que je suis ici j'en ai vu des
jours et je peux vous dire qu'on a cinq
grands types de peur une classification
une hiérarchisation qui n'est pas
homologué qui n'est pas scientifique
on sait juste ont ressenti c'est
arbitraire
c'est ce que j'ai vu à travers ces
années par exemple vous aviez des
percussions classiques comme la peur des
maladies la peur des armes des objets en
temps la peur des araignées la peur de
certains
la peur des oiseaux et bien l'araignée
par exemple c'est pas l'arrêt morceau
qui fait peur aussi fait qu'alex wallach
qu'elle montre comme ça tous cons elle
va nous mordre et c'est celle-là c'est
là le point clé parce que ce qui se
passe c'est que l'ena teinte à notre
enveloppe corporelle et maintenant
l'intégrité physique
c'est la première peur qu'on voit
ensemble la peur de la mutilation
c'est comment nous on a peur de perdre
un membre d'être amputé s'il est la peur
que notre corps se détériore
il ya des pleurs qui sont beaucoup plus
symboliques comme par exemple la peur
d'eux dans un ascenseur
bloquer ou bien la peur d'être au mieux
d'une foule vous savez l'agoraphobie ou
encore lié à la peur un père veut se
marier à part peut-être même d'emménager
avec son conjoint il ya tout ça c'est
notre grand père la seconde paire combat
ensemble c'est la peur de la perte de
l'autonomie
vous savez quand on est par exemple
enseveli paralysé immobilisé bloqué
coincé toutes ces peurs là c'est la même
peur cette peur de la perte de
l'autonomie
cette peur que nous impose quelque chose
qui n'est pas notre volonté on va pas
être célibataire toute sa vie rassurez
vous on peut combattre ses peurs
et heureusement sinon on aurait encore
peur de ça comme quand on était petit
alors il ya plusieurs manières
d'affronter ses peurs
pas de chien la ville en charge un petit
peu quand on grandit on affronte
forcément quelques-unes de ses peurs non
habilitées à les affronter c'est comme
ça qu'on devient une grande personne
c'est pour ça que il ya des tribus qui
ont des rites initiatiques una prendre
ses peurs pour devenir un adulte
il ya deux manières aux par exemple
halloween on va dédramatiser cette peur
on va se déguiser en ce qui nous fait
peur de sorte à s'en moquer et un coup à
faiblir finalement la menace
il ya aussi une autre manière par
exemple ça peut être la tcc la thérapie
comportementale et cognitive
en fait on va se déconditionner
progressivement de ce qui nous fait peur
prenez la peur des chiens par exemple et
dont on va être confronté au mot chien
puis l'image d'un chien puis à la vidéo
d'un chien puis à un chien en situation
vais je pas sûr que ça suffise à
convaincre m pardon ça fait longtemps
que j'ai enfin prendre votre temps et
voulait juste une chambre tu retrouves
je vous donnais une chance
jamais deux sans trois
celle ci
à 308 passé une excellente nuit et fait
attention
je n'ai surtout d'art verrier pas non
plus céder gratuitement
vous avez peur vous savez qu
c'est simplement un mécanisme de défense
instinctif qui vient lorsqu'il ya un
danger
c'est le coeur bat plus fort plus vite
transpire mes muscles se tendent toi
processus de survie
la france arrive il ya deux choses que
fut le ca
d'abord il va analyser la situation elle
a par exemple dans une chambre
ce qui arrive
un peu dans l'embarras si tu te cours
c'est compliqué
or il analyse cette situation initiale
ils essaient fois tout vient la menace
est ce que je suis apte un défend
ce que tu es aussi ça vaut ces analyses
et les gros sur ce sujet c'est un
exemple un homme se lève
denard coups de hache cerveau et enfin
de voir si mon corps a les ressources
pour le contrer ou ses confrères je vais
devoir fuir
pascal à ce que
les jambes ont cette capacité c'est
entendu
eh oui
g
rien sinon elle
c'est d'ailleurs une partie le thalamus
qu'avant de l'information sensorielle
je vais ensuite envoyer un signal à
lamidat qui va essayer de savoir si
cette situation de danger ou non et en
fonction envoyer un signal à son tour à
l'hypothalamus qui l'a lancé le
processus
processus d'auto défense c'est pour ça
que parma d'avoir peur en ça permet de
conscientiser si nous entourent permet
si jamais il ya mangé
m
l'essai
je
c'est la troisième fois ce soit une peur
compensant la peur de la séparation de
la peur de l'abandon être délaissés
délaissé par les autres par autrui
transparent
on se sent à partir un monde
j'ignore totalement sa détention
c4est ce que j'espère
non
bien dormi au des moyens ses placards
qui compte en voyant mon corps là depuis
hier soir jean marc on retombe sur cette
peur de la mutilation
j'ai appris que vous étiez déjà un jeu
je suis un peu déçu je vous aimais bien
c'est quoi ces jeux
notre hôtel n'est pas assez bien pour
vous peut-être un poème le titre on peut
me dire je ne veux pas que ça va pas
mais avec seulement se vexer les
sensations qui est très proche de jeu
par loupé son permis ou un examen ou
faire une vanne et avoir personne qui
rigole cesser tout ce qui touche une
confiance finalement et c'est la
quatrième peur c'est la peur de la mort
de lego c'est la peur de toutes ces
choses qui vous nous tous chez nous et
notre estime de lui
intéressant c'est intéressant parce que
cette peur qui est très liée à la
dernière la dernière qui est une peur la
peur suprême c'est la peur de
disparaître
mais attention pas seulement au sens de
mourir la peur de la mort fait partie de
la peur de disparaître de la peur de
l'extinction
mais cette typologie elle est bien plus
large que ça elle regroupe toutes les
autres folies qui aurait pour objet de
supprimer notre identité comme le fait
de devenir fou et de ne plus savoir qui
en est par exemple ou que plus personne
ne se souvienne de nous du jour où l'on
vous j'espère que toute cette petite
mise en scène vous aura plu c'est assez
intéressant de se pencher sur la peur la
peur c'est des choses qui évoluent
beaucoup et qui évoluera beaucoup c'est
il ya des peurs qui disparaissent qui
ont disparu comme les gaulois par
exemple ils avaient peur que le ciel
leur tombe sur la tête et les peurs qui
persistent comme la peur des serpents
elle peur des araignées et des peurs qui
arrive on sait notamment avec l'ajout
d'icônes en train d'utiliser la des
peurs liées à la réalité virtuelle
par exemple on va avoir peur de la
réalité parce qu'en fait on est trop
bien la réalité virtuelle
alors on risque d'avoir peur de ne pas
savoir dissocier la réalité de la
réalité virtuelle
donc ça c'est intéressant et amusant à
imaginer et marc le temps faut pas
diaboliser ces outils là parce que a
contrario ils peuvent nous aider à
vaincre certaines phobies par exemple il
ya déjà des applications qui existent
sur le vertige on va nous mettre en
situation on est au bord du vide et du
coup ça nous permet d'affronter cette
part là donc voilà ça c'est intéressant
tout cas j'espère que cette expérience
vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à partager
et n'hésitez pas à vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait pour pas rater les
prochaines vidéos on sera sûrement pour
un prochain clip
ciao genre du lot la piste ben ali